What's up with that? I mean, why did you actually decided on quitting...
...right after spending pretty much, I don't know 16 or 14 years...
...of, you know, having classical violin?
Well, I really enjoyed doing a lot of different things in music...
...and I wanna be the most, you know, the best musician that I can be.
And I felt that if I just stayed with classical,...
...I'm missing out on a lot of different types of music that are also a lot of fun...
...like jazz and hip-hop. And so, I wanted to take a break from classical and try something new.
And I'm really happy that I've made that decision...
...because I think, it's made me a much better musician for it.
This is your first time singing in Japanese, right?
Yeah.
And so, you seem to be like having fun at the same time struggling, and...
...how are you coping with it?
I'm sure you can speak some Japanese.
I can but I keep making mistakes, like the other day,...
...I wanted to say thank you for having us play for you, which is...
...right? But I said,...
And that's like totally wrong.
Did you get run over?
Yeah, it was like...
...and then Stan, he's like,...
...you just said, "Thank you for running me over with your car."
That's not what I wanted to say!
So, you know, it's a challenge and I get really nervous when I speak Japanese...
...because I'm so scared that I'm gonna make that one mistake...
...that totally changes the meaning of what I wanna say.
So, I'm practicing as much as I can but I'm sure I'll keep making mistakes.
At least, they're funny mistakes so it's okay.